ANDREW BROGOON: Hey, everybody.
I'm Andrew Brogoon, and welcome
back to the Mobile Ads Garage.
Today, with the help of my
partner, Gary the Graphics Guy,
we're going to talk about test
ads, why they're important,
and a couple of
ways to enable them.
All right, let's
start with the why.
Test ads are kind of like the
seat belts in a drag racer.
Not the sexiest
part of the machine,
but they will save you
from a ton of trouble.
When you use test ads properly,
you help insure three things.
Number 1, advertisers
are charged correctly.
Number 2, everybody's stats and
reporting can log correctly,
including yours.
And 3, you avoid one of
the most common causes
of account suspensions.
Let's take a look
at these real quick.
Number 1 is pretty easy.
If you test with
live ads, the server
thinks your impressions and
click throughs are real,
which means they get
logged and somebody ends up
paying for them.
That may not sound like much,
but when tens of thousands
of developers do it at
once, all over the world,
that's a lot of
imaginary traffic
to ask somebody to pay for.
Number 2, accurate
stats and reporting.
If you're testing with live ads,
all those impressions and click
throughs record
it as real, which
means your reporting is off,
as are the numbers for the ads
and advertisers themselves.
Last and probably highest
on the list of your concerns
is that test ads help you
avoid account suspensions.
If you're working on your app,
loading and clicking live ads,
the server is going to say,
hey, this person just clicked
on like, 10 ads in a row.
That looks like click fraud, and
then down comes the ban hammer.
All right, so that's the why.
Now, let's talk how.
The good news about
implementing test ads
is that there's two
fairly simple ways to do
it, one of which is dead easy.
Fair enough.
The quickest way to make
sure you get test ads
is just to use one of our
predefined test ads units
when loading ads.
We have a list of them at our
Android and iOS testing guides.
Each format is
covered, and you can
take the ad units
right out of there
and pop them into your apps.
Plus, this video that
you're watching right now
is embedded in the
test ads guide.
So if you're watching
me in an embedded player
right now instead
of on YouTube.com,
chances are you're on
the right page already.
Just pause me and scroll down.
If you use those
test ad unit IDs,
you'll see a creative like this.
It'll probably declare
itself as a test ad
so you'll know right away
that you're doing it right.
All right, so that's the first
way of implementing test ads.
The other is to use test
devices when making your request
object.
These APIs for
Android, IOS, and Unity
allow you to register
a particular device
to receive test ads, even
when using your own ad units.
You pass them a hash
device ID and the SDK
will make sure that when
that device runs the code
and makes a request, it
always gets a test ad.
That's a good question.
They're shown in the
Android or iOS device logs
when an ad is requested.
Just look for a line that
references test devices,
copy the ID, and
you're good to go.
Another good question.
You can use one of the tested
unit IDs I mentioned above,
or just download and
run one of our samples.
You'll see the device
hash in a log either way.
One of the advantages of using
test devices with your own ad
units is that you're not
stuck with the default test
creatives.
Instead, you get dummy
versions of production ads
that are clearly
tagged as test ads.
So you get to see a wide
variety of creatives
while still using test ads.
Plus, when you use
your own ad units,
your mediation
configurations are still
in play, which means you'll
sometimes see the AdMob test
ad, but you'll also
get mediated ads.
That can help you test
mediated ad units.
But be careful.
You can see, there's
no test ad label here.
Not every network is capable
of deciding at runtime
to show a test ad
instead of a real one.
Some have server side flags,
their own way of registering
test devices, things like that.
So make sure you check
the documentation provided
by the networks you're mediating
and configure them accordingly.
All right, that's about
it for this episode.
But I do have some
resources for you
down in the description
for this video.
First up, our links
to our testing guides
for Android, iOS, and Unity.
You'll find those test
units I mentioned,
along with some other good tips.
There's also a link to
our SDK support forum,
where you can post
technical questions
and get answers from
our support team.
And of course, if
you have a question
about this video or an idea for
a topic you'd like us to cover,
leave a comment below, and Gary
and I will see you next time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]